uh i i i i i see
oprah going i don't know where this is
going i'm not sure how to host this
right now because and what she says is
just
pretty surprising so it's inauthentic to
put other people first would you agree
or disagree the bible says you should
love yourself right
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live today is going to be
a real
life class today you guys ready for this
yeah all right
so
i came across this video i love the
internet you know it's like you know
it's just like this compilation of ideas
that can sit around for a long time i
came across an old video and uh you guys
can grow up on oprah winfrey oh my
goodness yeah yeah
okay so like give me some of your before
your time your experience
with her like i know she was talking
about people's bowel movements on there
one time i was like what are we talking
about here right yeah she has a lot of
different guests a lot of different
ideas world views but she kind of
portrays herself as a christian
but then i've seen a a
video where an audience member stood up
and said that's not right jesus is the
only way and all this stuff and oprah's
like i'm a christian jesus there's many
ways to get to jesus yeah i remember
that one of the mistakes that human
beings make is believing that there is
only one way
to live and that we don't accept that
there are diverse ways of being in the
world that there are millions of ways
and when she gets there she might call
it the life but her loving and her
kindness and her generosity brings her
if it brings her to the same point that
it brings you it doesn't matter whether
she called it god along the way or not
what about jesus
there is one way and only one
[Applause]
she really has sold herself i guess to
the american population maybe the world
population at this point um as being
sort of a spiritual leader she's kind of
fostering and guiding spiritual ideas so
she has this
particular
video series called life class and
i was kind of stumbling through some
videos and and this popped up and uh it
just really kind of peaked my attention
but before we get into this video i want
to ask you guys do you think it's
biblical to love yourself
yes
well you need some form i think i think
the bible naturally says you know you
should love others as you love yourself
okay yes very well taken that is my same
reasoning i think that we should love
ourselves
why what what would be the reason why
the bible would encourage that
i mean i don't know what love yourself
means exactly but take care of yourself
your body is the temple
um
hold yourself to high esteem in terms of
like knowing that you're
a child a child of god yeah
and i think also there's some there's
some really valid things if you if
you're mistreating yourself or you're
always down on yourself right it's it's
probably harder to
um
portray that love does that make sense
if if you're like depressed and it's
like poor me and my life is terrible and
stuff like this they say that actually
that's actually the hardest position to
see others
and so i kind of understand and that's
what piqued my interest about this so
i'm going to play a couple videos for
you i would say kind of what the world
says though like love yourself you got
to love yourself before you can love
others is the mind said that you're
first yeah you gotta love yourself
before you can love others when the
bible is totally flipped it's like
love your neighbor be a servant
and then you'll be rewarded in heaven
consider others better than yourself
okay now i want you to remember that be
a servant that's going to come up okay
we're going to talk about that look at
this video let's talk about it how many
of you are the strong ones
oh really
i believe it though not good no people
are saying yay you know i'm strong
yeah because and then beca and why isn't
that good because then first of all it's
probably inauthentic yeah you know that
you always put other people before you
okay what okay i was just gonna pause
for a second there do you notice
anything that's kind of interesting in
the very onset of this conversation
uh i i i i see
oprah going i don't know where this is
going i'm not sure how to host this
right now because and what she says is
just
pretty surprising so it's inauthentic to
put other people first would you agree
or disagree disagree
but that's inauthentic no we should put
others first well we aren't we taught to
do that though well maybe in our own
selfish nature
it's okay so it's really interesting
inauthentic means authentic well like
it's like it's like really you're not
your natural self is not going to put
other people right first right that's
how i kind of understood that right
that's a true statement i believe we are
sold to sin and therefore we are
naturally selfish okay oh so i want you
to follow this thing i want you to
follow this law just saying it's not
natural to put other people first yes
but you put yourself last how you treat
yourself is how you treat god so you're
putting god last
because you are the representative of
god in your life come on with it
how do you feel about that wait wait
this is a slippery slope i know that's
how they you
are putting yourself first therefore
that's how you're going to treat god so
if you're naturally putting yourself
last that's how you're going to treat
god
hmm
i don't know i i'm seeing a lot of
similarities with the way she talks with
the people the examples on the law of
attraction video the law of attraction
entering the church
she just seems like
yeah make make yourself
now i'm gonna hang on that for a second
because i think it's very interesting
that mikey's recognizing this because
mikey put together that video on the law
of attraction
so he's familiar with this concept and
he's recognizing something about it
right off the bat
let nothing be done by selfish ambition
or conceit but in lowliness of mind let
each of us esteem others better than
himself oh powerful so does the bible
tell us we need to put ourselves first
ever can you think of a bible verse
he does a whole parable about sitting at
the
worst seat of the table versus the best
seat beside the person and
the definition of love according to
jesus is one who lays down his own life
for his friends you're definitely not
putting yourself first in that situation
during the uh the time the last supper
right before jesus goes to the cross
what what what were each of the
disciples sitting there discussing
who was gonna deny him who's gonna be
the
best who's gonna be the best
they're literally at the night that
jesus is going to go forward and and
what's very fascinating about that story
is if you remember jesus told his
disciples go to this room you'll find
this room in this particular location
where there is a water basin right
and
a washing of the feet to a jew was like
you washing your hands before you sit
down and eat so the information that the
bible actually tells us is that there's
a room over here we're gonna have this
supper together and there's water in the
room so we know that the disciples
didn't show up and no there's no water
why didn't anyone wash anyone's feet
they're sitting there discussing who's
gonna be the best so what does jesus
have to do
takes off his tunic like a servant
lowers himself lower than low and does
the job of a servant
i want you to keep that in mind
listen to this bible verse
be devoted to one another love and honor
one another above yourselves
can you think of a bible verse that ever
is telling you to put yourself first
before anyone else
no i can't think of one can you
all right
listen to this let no one seek his own
good but the good of his neighbor i hear
constantly over and over and over again
that we need to be others focused in
fact that's how i imagine heaven to be
right is an environment where we are
always consciously being aware of other
people
not our own selves i think a lot of the
problems that we see in our world today
is simply because we are thinking of
ourselves before we're thinking of other
people selfishness selfishness is seems
to be the rule of this world okay so
listen to her
well that's logic deep
now that just was an aha moment you
don't have nothing right now where's my
writing tools dude
now how you i've never heard it put that
way before yeah because you are the
representation of god in your life and
you put you last
and put other people ahead of you which
means you're putting other things and
other people ahead of god in your life
really yes really
okay so i think right here oprah is
genuinely going i don't know what to do
with this
wouldn't you agree you know i think
what would it show the world if you as a
representative as a
representation of god
always put others first wow is that what
god's like god is thinking of you and
you and you and he cares about every
little person he gives to the needy and
he
homes the widow and all this stuff but i
feel like there's a blurred line between
it almost feels it almost seems like
god isn't an individual person separate
from us it's like this god is in you
type of thing that's interesting that
you're recognizing that makes sense yeah
okay whatever i do
automatically means
we're gonna get to where she's getting
this information from and it's and it's
interesting to me that you're picking up
on that
kim can we summarize what she just said
again because i i kind of feel i need
the context sure all put together sure
so she's basically saying that we we if
we are putting other people before our
own selves that we are a representation
of god in our lives
so when we put ourselves first that's
literally how we're going to treat god
that's what she's basically saying in a
summarization okay all right and so
oprah right here is just like wait wait
i'm trying to process this and she's
going wow that's really deep matthew 23
11-12 says but he that is greatest among
you shall be your servant and whoever
shall exalt himself shall be abased and
that
shall be shall humble himself shall be
exalted so the bible's giving you this
picture of what jesus is as our
representative he was the king of the
universe and he humbled himself and came
down as a lowly servant right washing
people's feet what an amazing god is
that is that not a god that you want to
serve one that will actually demonstrate
what that's like
this theology that is kind of coming out
of this lady is
is not a representation of what god is
like it's kind of like when you
if if you voted and i don't do that but
like you want to vote for somebody who
has been where you're at not somebody
who's just been rich all the time like
somebody who's lived a normal life same
with mayor or whatever right you want to
vote in somebody that can identify with
you
because then they're going to
cater their laws and everything to
to be fair right that's right that's
right and here this is kind of a lesson
in discernment right where are we
getting our information from how do we
really know what's real what's not real
what sounds good what doesn't sound good
you've got to read the bible yeah you
have to understand and the more that you
spend time with the bible the more that
you understand how god is with us and
what he's actually asking of us yeah
because i bet there's a lot of
christians who aren't spending time in
their word they're just sitting in the
pew every once a week they're seeing
this and they're like that sounds great
that sounds great listen to what um
oprah then asks this question
but i i thought i thought god said jesus
said what you do to the least of these
and how you treat other people you treat
your brother like yourself okay that's
when you're getting into the service but
in your life yes you've got to be as
good to you as you want to be to god in
order to be of service to others in the
world
thank you
[Music]
so she's like
swinging this conversation she brings
god into it but then she's like look you
that's that's service so service is
separate other than the way that you're
gonna treat god right so like this
division of like yeah yeah that has
really nothing to do with the way that
you need to focus on how you're treating
you and where you're putting yourself in
this picture well i think it
what she's saying is
basically
until you love yourself you can't love
others so until you treat yourself well
um
you can't go out and do that service
stuff at least that's what how i'm
interpreting it from what she said she
said until you treat yourself like you
would treat god
okay and then the service part comes
after okay okay so let's see what she
says a little bit further down the line
here with this what if doing kind things
for others helps you love yourself more
i mean we talked about that on another
show about depression i was like look if
you're going through depression don't
cut yourself and these things go out and
like if you're thinking about committing
suicide
before you do that think about all the
good you could do for somebody else go
out into the community and feed the
homeless or something
you actually have purpose now because
you
helped change this whole person's life
if this is your last day on earth or
whatever go do these things first and
not only are you helping them but it
might actually make you feel better
about yourself okay so i'll give you a
practical example of what you just said
right there do you remember we had my
brother brock on the show and brock went
to the tornado victims that that that
tornado ripped 300 miles and
wrecked all the the people in the candle
factory and they all died do you
remember that
do you remember that that when he got on
they showed up at this environment where
basically one house was saved everything
around it was totally destroyed but
obviously there's houses and stuff on
the house and when they went and knocked
on the guy's door it was an ex like
military guy who was basically like my
life is over and and i'm done and he was
drunk and he was totally like i just i
don't even want to live anymore and he
was basically like my whole life is
ruined my house has ruined my existence
is ruined my money's ruined everything
like this i don't want to live anymore
and you remember what brock said that
they actually did with him
they invited him to go and help other
people and he said immediately his life
was transformed wow
he immediately jumped in there it was
like a change that came over him and he
all of a sudden was like i know how this
military training i know this medical
stuff i want to go and help this person
and it was through the helping of all
the other people that immediately gave
him purpose in life wow so i want to
submit to you
that what she's saying i understand this
logic of like if i can't treat myself
correctly then i'm not going to be able
to love other people
but the devil wants us to constantly be
focused on us
on us
and and listen to this logic that she
kind of swings this around towards the
end
and so many of us think that you know
we're going to get brownie points in
heaven like we're going to get
interested in the box seat section
if you know if we just give and give and
give and give now here's what the course
in miracle says which i love the course
in miracle says that when you give to
others to the degree that you sacrifice
yourself you make the other person a
thief
because
when you start sacrificing yourself for
other people
you make them a thief
because they're stealing from you what
you need and they don't even know it
what okay dude she's bringing out a
course of miracles isn't that alice
bailey right dude so we're gonna get
into this so we're gonna get into this
we're gonna get
this is why it's so dangerous to take
somebody in our world and go oh well
they're quoting jesus or they're using
the bible or they're talking about the
spiritual thing and you don't quite put
all these things together what she just
mentioned right there i want to show you
guys where a course of miracles is and
what they actually believe because we're
going to get into that okay but look at
this bible verse right here first john 3
17 but if anyone has the world's goods
and sees his brother in need yet closes
his heart against him what does it say
there mikey how does god's love abide in
him
if you have the ability to help somebody
and you don't
he's asking a very valid question
how is god's love inside of you if you
have the means and the ability to help
somebody and you don't
what does that mean
what she just said was that if i'm not
putting myself first you coming in and
me sacrificing and giving to you is you
stealing from me because i need that
thing you become a thief now
like how twisted is that mentality
right yeah the bible also tells us not
to become weary of doing good
also so you should always have other
people's good in mind god will supply
all the need he will he will give
abundantly above and beyond anything
that we can ask
and if we ask
for the purpose of doing god's will and
god's will is for the salvation of
everyone right seek ye first the kingdom
of god and all these things will be
added unto you if seeking the kingdom is
about others focused and helping others
and he says
pure religion we have a t-shirt of i
can't remember verbatim but it says pure
religion is
feeding the
needy
you know helping the widows and all this
stuff
pure religion is helping others seek
first the kingdom and then all these
things will be added unto you he's not
going to let us be destitute when we're
helping others i don't think you can now
give god no
and and to what um
britney was saying galatians 6 9 is what
you were saying yeah
and let us not grow weary in world doing
for in due season which will reap if we
faint
yeah
it's important to know the bible and to
know it to the point where when you
start hearing these things you go hey
that's not right that's not what the
bible says go look it up just because
someone is famous does not mean that
they have it all together and this is a
classic example of that so she brought
up this book called the course in
miracles now you've never heard of this
book before never so if it's called a
course in miracles what do you think
that this would be about just off the
top of your head
the course in mira a class on miracles
i wanna guess how to make your own
miracles
and you're in control of that i guess
yeah okay this sounds like it would be
biblical do you either you guys i know
you don't answer this um do you
recognize any of these faces that are on
here
i know oprah okay anyone else
nope nope nope nope nope nope i actually
recognized two but i don't know my name
this indian looking guy in the white
jacket deepak chopra oh yeah
oh eckhart's holy okay okay so who who
are these guys wait who's that guy yeah
who's who's that guy at the end cartooly
he wrote a book that was on oprah's
reading list um
she always has him on her show it's a
new age book absolutely it's like
i can't these are all new age
gurus one of them probably was like
author of the secret or something wait
he did the four the four agreements
i don't remember as a book called the
four agreements yeah so anyway i didn't
know much about this book i just started
like looking it up and these are all
people that have like really endorsed
this book
so so when i started to see some of
these pictures of these guys going hey
they're endorsing this way of thinking i
was like i know exactly where they're
going with this thing
so she has one of these ladies one of
the ladies that was on here um super
bowl so super soul sunday what would you
think that this show would be about so i
actually am familiar with this show okay
she put it into a book but they
like oprah brings a bunch of different
um
people to come and talk and some of them
are like uh yeah i guess their new age
but they are they're musicians and they
have like these different philosophies
and they all come and talk about like
meditation or mindfulness and just all
these different things just kind of a
spiritual side of life
and she also has a book i think she
published two books where
it's a beautiful book also beautiful
photography words in front of it it's a
very well put together book um but it
just has all these different things on
how to like improve your life in like a
spiritual sense
a lot of this kind of self-help stuff
really has a lot of crossover into a lot
of this new age ideas so here's a little
clip from um there's she's uh
interviewing one of these ladies for her
soul or super soul sunday but in a
course in miracles it says that for
every person there is a highly
individualized curriculum the idea of
the holy spirit the idea that the
universe is invested in your
self-actualization which is the same
thing saying the universe is invested in
your enlightenment so you will go
through the same thing as saying god
wants you to be enlightened to be happy
to be in love
with life to be living in love and to
forgive and be forgiven right that's all
different words for the same thing and
and one of the other things is that
and i think everybody who's watching
this understands that this planetary
experience is about life lessons right
and what you were just saying is that
everybody has an individualized
curriculum exactly that belongs just to
you i know people are going to call out
that hand sign right there
i think it's very interesting that you
are talking about a very new age idea
and you're showing exactly you're
showing a very new age eastern
philosophy
sign
i don't believe at a random moment you
know some people talk and and i've seen
pictures of people you know doing
something where they're like mentioning
something and they're putting their
hands together in that way screenshot
that and then exactly
exactly no listen i'm not uh doing
anything that's true i'm just giving an
illustration but same for illustration
purposes some people may just talk with
like that with their hands i don't
believe that's what's going on right
here she purposefully used that hand
sign during this particular
thing because she's cutting across a
very new age idea about the universe
so how do you self act actualization so
how do you decide that
i don't i don't have 100 confirmation
that that is what she's doing i'm just
saying it's very interesting that she's
using a very eastern philosophy and then
giving you a very eastern philosophical
hand sign at the same time like that
could be totally coincidence i just am
making that statement of saying
i think that was more purposeful there
is there's three things it could be
could be coincidental it could be
purposeful or it could be spiritually
led
i mean she could have something
in her that is guiding her thoughts and
her ideas that is perhaps leading also
her to say hey let's use this hand
signal yeah they could have prayed
before the conversation right
the right thing yeah right other people
that are watching that that are maybe
more familiar with that or are huge yoga
practitioners or something maybe feel
more comfortable if you see these kind
of things being thrown out there i have
no idea but
for the sake of just uh not spending too
much time on the hand sign um i want to
get to the bottom of what is this book
of miracles so i didn't know much about
it so i started doing a little bit of
research and finding some people this is
a new age practitioner that used to
follow teach and everything because
there's classes there's huge groups of
people that will go around and teach
from this book of miracles
and she was one of these and she is
going to talk a little bit about where
it actually comes from and i want you to
pay attention to this i wanted to
talk with you today about a book called
a course in miracles you may or may not
have heard of it it's often referred to
as the new age bible
it's something that i studied for
probably about 20 years when i was in
the new age and it really resonated with
me because it seemed so familiar it
seemed so much like the christian
science theology that i was
raised with and there's a reason for
that the woman who
is the scribe often called the channel
of a course in miracles helen shukman
was raised in a household with christian
science influences
and so it took the beliefs that i was
raised with that
were the opposite of the bible
and took it to the next level so for a
long time i studied and read a course in
miracles every single day and it
completely influenced my teachings that
i was writing about in the new age
so i wanted to
make this warning because i still get
letters from people who say
well a course in miracles says that
you're supposed to forgive and see this
is where
the enemy the devil
likes to mix in truth and lies to hook
us in of course
forgiveness is essential the bible says
that
but what the course in miracles doesn't
tell you is that it's slowly telling
people that everything in the bible is
false and that the course in miracles is
true
so we had guests on our show about this
very thing the older couple and it was
called uh the new new age rage it shows
a crucifix and crosshairs that's what he
was saying he got sucked into this book
they used to go around and teach from
that book yeah yeah so this is christian
science material this course in miracles
i'm confused
being led by the same spirit yes so you
know when they're when they're talking
about christian science um there's a lot
of christian themed
ideas that are kind of incorporated into
this but it's very vastly different than
christianity
so it's kind of a bit of a of a
deception to call something sort of
christian something
because you're going to immediately
think like oh well this is talking about
the same ideas and if they're talking
about the holy spirit they're talking
about the same concepts as the bible
forgiveness and this and that but notice
what she said
the entire purpose of this book is to
show you that the bible is false and
that this book is true which is
literally what the mormons do too man
i've had
not just me but some friends of mine in
california who are also on the show
michaela and daniel they
they uh would invite them over and
continuously talk to them and say can we
do a study of the bible and they'd be
like well you know and this is what they
did to me too they said i said what do
you think about this verse this verse in
this verse because they were telling me
that
joseph bates as i said joseph joseph
smith
got these writings from
a deceased person
the spirit of a deceased person i said
what do you think about these verses
that say the
dead know nothing and all that and i
said well you know the bible is really
old it's been translated many times you
know why don't you just read the book of
mormon and pray the holy spirit if ask
if it's true he said that's what i did
and
so it always comes back to know this is
the book not the bible anything that
encourages you to basically utilize some
piece of material over the bible if
there's a discrepancy between the bible
and this book go with this book don't go
with the bible anything that's doing
that i don't care what it is
i think is a deception
god's word is the line of truth we have
to order ourselves after that line
so look at how she breaks this down
because i want to show you like what the
real teaching of this is and this may be
interesting in light of some of our
other work
so the history of a course in miracles
goes back to 1965
when a woman named helen shukman
who was raised by jewish parents who her
mother also was
steeped in christian science
the unity school of christianity those
were my two
church upbringings but also theosophy
which is spiritualism
helen blavatsky for those of you
familiar with her and the channeling in
quotes of
ascended masters so that's her
background helen shukman was also an
associate professor of medical
psychology at columbia university
college
and it was then that she heard a voice
and the voice told her this is a course
in miracles write this down that she
said was from jesus and that he was
trying to correct what people believed
about him
i want to say that that really hooked me
in
we're saying the same thing over and
over seeing the same thing over and over
and again and replacement gods
yeah why is it the movies why is it the
alien topic why is it the whatever you
want to call it the self-help
eastern philosophy why does it always
stem back to jesus isn't who he really
said he was or there's some
misunderstanding around jesus and we
need to correct people's understanding
of who jesus is right yeah aliens from
millions of light years away come all
the way here to probe your butt and tell
you that jesus is who you think he is
and
you
can be christ never heard him put that
way but yes
and then you know grant morrison yeah
talking about how he
had a vision of christ he said i
immediately knew this was christ when he
was going he was writing the books
the comics he was experiencing what he
was writing so this is like
i don't know manifesting things into
existence
and when he started feeling this
scary presence he cried out to the god
of his parents he said jesus and he saw
who he immediately knew was the gnostic
christ
who said you're dying and he said what i
have to do to not die and he said
write your stories based on what we tell
you to write yeah share the light is
what he actually told him you need to
work for us and as long as you say
you're going to work for us i will let
you live and he thinks he's now working
for jesus and just like you said about
mormonism i have a lot of good friends
that are mormons and i i even on
facebook i will probably see this even
but um i and and they often come to my
house just like you but their backstory
i'm just saying it as it is their back
story is jesus came
to america before it was uh inhabited by
the current inhabitants they found gold
plates in the ground and jesus brought
this to the native americans jesus
brought a new gospel to correct it so
this is a different gospel than what is
in the bible that's why they want you to
read the book of mormon is there a
scripture about that if anyone gives you
a new gospel right yes
this topic is touching such a wide
variety of topics i mean have you ever
heard the discussion on the holy spirit
whether there is a holy spirit whether
he's real or not and the end conclusion
of that is jesus isn't really who he
we think he is he's not he's been
begotten
it falls apart right why is the attack
always on who jesus is
because you've got a question
you gotta question that that's satan's
agenda and if jesus is the ultimate
model of who we need to be
who he's going to
put his covering on us and create us to
be in the eyes of god right
all of that deals with who the character
of jesus really is listen to this
helen shukman
took down the dictation
thinking that it was from jesus with
the belief that jesus was setting
straight the record of what he was
really trying to say in the bible
but it doesn't make sense because jesus
is the same yesterday today and tomorrow
and why would jesus come along and say
that everything in the bible was false
right
she brings up a very simplistic idea
but you only know that
if you know what the bible says
that's why it's important we've got to
have a relationship with god
in his word you got to study it you got
to know what it is because these spirits
have nothing on us
if we're like no that's not what the
bible says
and i can see that error what she just
said about how this lady got the
writings reminds me of
the the movie the documentary we had
chris lang on here talking about beware
beware of angels man those people were
a group of people who wanted to study
the bible they prayed god we want to
know more we want to know deeper truth
we want you to give us an angel because
in the in the old testament there's
people saw angels and an angel did start
appearing before them 106 of them and
they wrote stacks of writings from these
angels for five years this angel had
their
trust
and to the point where he said you gotta
kill these people because they're
demon-possessed
and they did it yeah
go ahead you need to see that
documentary if you have ever had anyone
in your life that says that they have
some private information some esoteric
understanding um some special knowledge
that nobody else has and you're the only
one be leery of that
because that is where that story took
those individuals they were genuinely i
think wanting to have a real
relationship with god and and they were
genuinely wanting to to experience more
than just a an intellectual
understanding they wanted some physical
proof of that and can i i'm looking at
this for both sides right now and i'm
not counting what you say i want to
preface that with that but i do believe
that good spirits can come to us in our
day and i believe that there have been
some in in eastern
north south east west yeah the eastern
side of the world
and i believe that they have come to
some people that really want to truly
believe the truth and said i am jesus
this is the truth and they have
presented themselves like the muslims
the muslims yeah exactly
but i believe the bible says we need to
test the spirits yeah that's right test
the spirits to the bible standard not to
anything else that's right that's right
good point so my question i guess my
area of concern is the fact that they
did genuinely want
um like they were generally praying to
god so why would
a demon come to them
so i think the difference but like how
does that open up that i think the
difference between what brad is talking
about god has revealed himself
throughout history we have examples of
this there's been stories uh missionary
stories you name it i've heard stories
of where very supernatural things have
happened i think the difference is if
you're sitting there inviting it
constantly inviting it you got to
understand there is spiritual warfare
going on around you all the time and if
somebody's kicking back going this
person needs physical examples of this
and if i give them physical examples
they're going to listen to anything that
i say exactly what happened in in that
case of the individuals at the bible
study that were asking for
representations of angels well the angel
showed up and then he got their trust
over years and then told them that they
needed to murder the other people in the
room and they listen
alert they listen to it but yeah yeah
sorry spoiler alert so so there's a
bigger thing going on here than just
individuals even because there's a whole
court up here saying okay well
i think that miss brittany down here
will do this if you do this remember the
story of job right i will do this if you
do this and god says okay go ahead and
do that that's what happened and there's
so much theology behind this one story
about how god said i will send a lying
spirit god didn't send a lying spirit
but there is a court up in heaven and
they're saying i want to go down there
and deceive this person would you let me
so i can prove my point and god says
okay
all right but i will show you that
ultimately i'm correct
and that's what happens so either one
either side can come to us but it's up
to us to decide yeah
that's why thessalonians talks about
those that love not the truth god sent a
strong delusion i don't believe that god
was trying to deceive people god's
allowing he's removed his protection and
allowed that deception to come in the
door and that's what we are called to do
to test
their god is not promising if we
sign up with him that we will have no
attack against us oh yeah so that's
where i believe the difference is is i
think when you start opening yourself up
because you want this special experience
this special confirmation
rather than god's going look i've given
you all the confirmation in the word of
god like you should be able to read that
and and see it we know how that whole
bible stories have all played out we're
living in the end we have so much
information that is confirming what god
is telling us to be true
um i think when you start seeking i need
more i need more i need more i want to
see this i think that's when the devil
can step in and he can easily get your
attention by giving you some visual sign
which will then trump the
information that you've learned
when they ask jesus give us a sign and
all this he said an adulteress
generation you are inside that's for a
because his word is solid his word is
how he speaks to this and so
like you were just talking about all the
disciples were like beheaded boiling oil
beaten flogged
crucified
and and to think that we're not having
like
that this is just everything's going to
be good because we're christian and all
this now yeah i think we need to arm
ourselves with the truth and also as a
shield is the faith in that word of god
you build that faith in that word of god
and that is how jesus beat the devil i
believe that's how we are called to beat
the devil and i believe that all this
other stuff that you're hearing in the
media and even if they're using the same
terminology holy spirit
faith
forgiveness those are all christian
ideas but the way that that's framed is
to build distrust in the word of god and
change what you believe to be real look
at what she said i want to hear what
britney's thinking she's got her gears
turning in her head over there she's
just going like this i just
i just think it's crazy though because i
think
the character or satan tries to ruin the
character of god and just make god seem
like this really evil person
but yet he like naturally i think we all
are attracted to god because satan
masquerades himself as an angel of light
you know he's coming on the scene as
christ
so it's like
if we're going to be attracted to to
lucifer pretending to be jesus then we
would be attractive to the actual jesus
if we really knew who he was because
it's just because look at that ultimate
deception if you are attracted to a
being that is not like god
even if he says he's god and portrays
this idea but the real character of
lucifer that's why thessalonians talks
about he will be in accordance to the
lawless one
he will be working just like satan would
work he's going against what god is
teaching in the bible right this is not
somebody who's portraying to be like
jesus and he acts like jesus and he's
asking you to do the same things of
jesus he's basically promoting himself
as this
lawless character where god jesus is not
gonna gonna he didn't come to break the
law he came to fulfill the law and so
who do you really understand who are you
following your eyeballs or are you
following what that character is really
all about and i believe that we learn
about the character of god by spending
time with him in his word what you just
said following your eyeballs being
deceived by your senses instead of what
the word says the word clearly says the
dead know nothing but you're believing
some dead spirit the word clearly says
how christ will return
if he's in the desert don't even look if
he's here in the secret place don't go
but yet we've been taught these twisted
biblical teachings in the church that
he's going to come this particular way
and there's going to be a thousand years
of peace which isn't in the bible find
it for me it doesn't say there's gonna
be a thousand years of peace on earth
but that's what the christian world is
expecting so when they see somebody
who's coming to bring peace and safety
they're gonna fall for it sudden
destruction will come upon them it's
even more than that too because i mean
not only we have our five senses to
worry about but if we do go there and
he's in the desert hey we go there i saw
him i thought him you know i know
he healed me yeah but we also got this
whole thing about you know i felt it
oh yeah yeah
you did a documentary
say every time someone gets abducted or
they have this vision of what happens
and they think that something happened
they always say i felt such warmth
towards these beings right that's a
sense that we don't
a sixth sense that we don't even fathom
right our thoughts can
essentially be
encouraged by these beings
friends what's what's really interesting
though and i'm not going to take this
too far but even mormonism says read our
book and you will feel a burning in the
bosom right yeah
what is that and a dead loved one will
tell you you're in the right religion
also people that's another misconception
that if it's of the devil it's gonna
feel scary and bad not true man pop some
ecstasy you're gonna feel love like
you've never felt that's not of god do
some new age meditation you're going to
feel love and all this even though it's
a serpent going to your brain right so
they tell you and even the fruit was
attractive yeah it was not something
that she was like oh my gosh that is
definitely an evil tree i should not be
there it was something that she was
drawn to that's right satan knows better
than that and what she was being
deceived with was the wisdom to be like
god that's a very notable thing to want
to be that's a good story you know yeah
i want to be more like god how is that a
deception you know it's like but clearly
that's where we all ended up in this
mess
so i want to show you the end of this um
this is what drew and attracted her and
i think it's very interesting to end on
this because of the conversation that
just ensued
i wanted the secret wisdom i was looking
for some secret and i thought that a
course in miracles would offer it
oh my goodness was i wrong
uh it's it's a book designed to lead
people away from
the real jesus and the real bible and it
is designed to have you follow a demon
disguised as jesus
so let's take a look at this
in the book
the light that was dark by warren b
smith this is his true story of how he
had his eyes opened to the truth of a
course in miracles
let me read you this if you have the
book
it's on page 144 he said for the better
part of a week i hold up in my study
with the course and the bible i studied
a course in miracles carefully and spent
hours pouring over the scripture
by the end of the week my old rolltop
desk was covered with notes file cards
charts and diagrams i had dissected the
course and the bible with a fine tooth
comb and i had found my answers my
conclusions were inescapable and
shocking
a course in miracles and the bible were
two completely different thought systems
that were mutually exclusive and
diametrically opposed in every degree
and warren says to my utter amazement a
course in miracles was the holy bible
turned upside down
the course had not updated or
reinterpreted the bible it had
completely rewritten it
okay
so before we dissect that look at this
verse and jesus answered to them see
that no one leads you astray for many
will come in my name saying i am the
christ and will lead many astray whoa
all these people who are saying yeah
i've reached christ consciousness i got
it even russell brand and stuff who i i
appreciate some of his videos but he's
on the wrong course if you will these
people are saying i am christ and
leading others astray being on youtube
telling everybody else hey this is how
you reach it so that guy that dissected
this how did he find out what was truth
and what wasn't truth
compared it with the
compared the counterfeit with the truth
the gender he had to hold them both up
together and look at the evidence that
was presented in either one and i
honestly believe if we were to do that
with most everything in life how does
this fit into the context of the bible
you will see and not be led astray even
if people are coming and telling you
this is about jesus christ and i am
jesus christ and i look like jesus
christ if you hold that up to what was
written in the word of god you will see
that there are false christs that are
trying to lead us away from god
you know this reminds me of the video
that we did the led light we did on
messiah i don't even think i was working
here yet but i watched it but remember
um the guy this he didn't really have
any origin jesus looking guy from the
middle east and then he was
in front of the um
oh what's that long tower yeah
reflection dc yeah he was walking on
water yeah he was walking on water and
everybody came around with their cell
phones like taking it was like a mystery
and directors were saying like you know
we just want to start a conversation
about what it would be like if
jesus was alive today yeah he was here
today or he came back in modern form
yeah but then he said in that show i
think we brought out the point that he
said we wanted to re-interpret what
people believe jesus they left they left
the whole ending it was like yes right
like they were like
yeah it was like is it jesus or is it
not and you don't know it never really
answered the question
um they just really wanted to get a
conversation started so it's interesting
because i thought it did a good job on
um
through the clips you guys showed the
modern way of it because especially with
social media i mean if people are just
literally you're going to see that on
your timeline if someone's walking on
water you know and that's going to be
like to and everybody like a lot of
things on social media you just soak it
up because you think okay well that's
video evidence given we have a lot of
technology now that can kind of warp
things but
yeah i think
that's why he said if they say he's in
the secret chambers if they say he's in
the desert don't even look he said don't
even look this is gonna be such a huge
deception that you will fall for it if
you even look at it don't even look and
and so even if
yeah you know we got david blaine and
chris angel and all these guys walking
on water and multiplying bread and doing
all the same things that jesus did
through some kind of
power because even satan turned two
staffs into snakes he could imitate the
same things that jesus was doing so just
because we have video proof or seeing it
with our own eyes somebody's saying yeah
i'm come to return and bring peace and
i'm walking on water
don't even look he said that's not how
i'm gonna return i'm gonna return with
like lightning flashes from the east to
the west and the wicked will be consumed
by the brightness of his coming and
we'll be changing a moment twinkling and
eye there ain't gonna be no time for
watching him walk around on water
he already did what he needed to do the
first time that's right
he said i go and prepare a place and
when i come i'm going to take you with
me he ain't coming to walk around on
water
and i believe that god's true followers
will hear his voice they know the voice
of the shepherd they know where he is
and they will recognize his voice when
he comes back i think it's interesting
what she said and what you have on here
is it says in the latter days many will
part depart from the faith giving heed
to seducing spirits and doctrines and
demons
you can't depart from a faith unless
you've been in it so christians like
oprah and like many others
they're departing from their faith
knowingly or unknowingly giving heed to
seducing spirits and doctrines and
demons man that's what we are seeing on
a mass scale and the media and
everything and they're the ones with the
platform yeah that's right don't just
trust people because they're on tv don't
even trust us
because we're on youtube
test everything if we bring up something
on this channel that you disagree with
from the bible communicate that with us
talk to us about it we'll engage with
you um if you see something that someone
else is bringing up and you're saying
hey
i'm i'm questioning that obviously do it
in a christian manner um but we feel
that uh
we are also on a journey of truth and so
we will engage and let's study these
things out together um but if you guys
keep this one thought in mind test
everything through the word of god no
matter what you see don't put your faith
and trust in man
actually know what you believe and study
out what you believe i believe will be
spared from an incredible deception that
is on us already and it's coming down
the pipe like a speeding train
and so i hope you were edified by
today's talk um
definitely check out some of these other
videos that we were talking about today
um because some of these concepts
actually cross over into a few of our
other videos so we'll put some links in
the description below but uh we hope you
are blessed by it we hope you will keep
watching our show thank you guys for
your prayers your support and thank you
for checking out little light studios
this is led live we'll see you guys next
week
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world
and in 1999 a movie titled the matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you